what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in let's get
started so today I am going to be
covering first former call her daddy
Superstar Sophia Franklin
um recently had a clip about what she
does on first date so I want to show you
guys Why Us females are so LED astray so
this woman had a podcast for 10
maybe it wasn't that long like five
years but in all honesty guys they were
a very big cultural influence it was two
girls living in New York City giving
their advice on dating and relationships
and the problem is is really really hot
chick she's a former hot chick now she's
like 30 you know
um she's a former hottie right a former
eight to ten and they just get away with
stuff and they get to do things and they
make all these rules for guys and
um Sims comply but those aren't the guys
they really want right so she's gonna
give her what she does as an expert on
first dates let's go
I'm not joking I have asked the last
three dudes I've dated for their bank
account info on the first date I don't
judge people's actions I look at the
intention behind it so like why do you
ask for that because I only want to date
a wealthy guy that has money valid so
you're getting straight to the point I
think you know I have a job I'm very
successful so I think I have everything
right to be like hi are we on the same
level or am I wasting my time okay so I
wanna I wanna point out a couple things
first of all you know women will say all
day that men cannot ask body count so
she can ask how much money he has on a
first date then should he ask body count
because he doesn't want to be with a
and the other issue she's having
is she's conflating the things that
women find attractive with the things
men find attractive
um men really don't care about your job
uh guys I I promise to God they do not
care uh they don't want to hear about
your work not really
um if anything I've even heard guys say
to avoid successful women because
they're more masculine so I think she's
roughly 30 years old you know she's been
in the public eye for a decade talking
about her sex life so not only is she
you know kind of there's a
10-year history of her talking about her
escapades that's going to be on the
internet forever is that what most men
are gonna want in a wife and a mother
and I'm telling you guys is someone who
grew up around these types of guys the
the one percenters the 10 top 10
percenters they they might they might
waste a couple years with the hoe they
might entertain her for a date you know
a couple months but I promise to God
it's not who they're taking home and
it's certainly not who they're having
children with men like Purity fertility
Youth and at this point you know her
Purity is pretty much gone
um oh and Beauty obviously Beauty
um and feminine you know there's more
but but Bare Bones right Purity
femininity Youth and the thing is
at 30 the youth is gone the Purity is
clearly gone and she thinks that the men
have to qualify to her when really she
has to qualify to the men because uh the
thing is the guys she's going after
are going to want to date the 21 22 year
olds
um and she has to show why she's
different why she's special but the
problem is we have a whole culture and
generation uh we have an entire culture
that acts like the men have to qualify
to us when the truth of the matter is
when you go for the top 10 20 of men
that have the money she's talking about
they have the leverage and not you
so you know me talking about these
topics I really think is helpful to
women
um because women we're just confused and
we're confused because of relationship
podcasts like this we're confused
because of the media or be we're
confused because of all the simps that
tell us what we want to hear and you
know I really thought I would get a very
nice thank you from the ladies that's
really what I thought I would get I
thought they would say pearl thank you
so much for all of your help Pearl I
appreciate you pointing this out
but no so I recently have had a hate
article made on me can you guys believe
it it says the terrifying rise
of all right female influencers
am I terrifying
oh my gosh
I thought I was a nice lady but I guess
I guess I'm terrifying now
all right they said toxic femininity is
real says a steely-eyed woman dressed in
a black lace top and bright red lipstick
with a red rose tucked behind her ear
the artificial background in her video
thrown with flowers and frilly
lampshades the woman is Daisy cousins
and she's one of the leading lights in
the female alt-right influencer movement
in Australia I've never heard of this
chick but she seems like a cool chick
from what they're saying you know if
they're writing articles she has more
than 200k subscribers on YouTube posting
regular videos with names like why
pretty women should never be feminists
and leftism makes young women miserable
the article delves into the emergence of
Women Within the far right and alt-right
movements
wow am I alt right now shedding light on
their pivotal role in disassemminating
extremist ideologies through digital
platforms and online spaces am I an
extremist
okay okay is it because I said men are
smarter than women or because I said
women shouldn't vote
I actually think these are really
logical opinions
I think they're really logical
am I am I extreme now you know it's the
time period honestly a hundred years ago
I would have just been a normal lady it
is not my fault I was born in this time
period okay
these women adopt a range of personas
and strategies to Garner attention often
portraying themselves as conservatives
traditionalists or proponents of the
Trad wife concept
prominent figures in this domain
includes Daisy cousins
I should reach out she seems like a nice
lady Pearl Davis Lena lock tough never
heard of her oh my girl Laura Loomer
Laura Loomer I we I tweeted her
sometimes you know
wow
so are they're calling me a prominent
figure
this is amazing
and they're saying I'm all right now wow
all right women active in these
movements hold a spectrum of viewpoints
spanning from conservative to extremists
where do you think they have me
what about when I said women are useless
okay I didn't say that till now
um their Adept use of online platforms
allow them to tackle issues like
feminism immigration transgender rights
and vaccination in ways that package
their message is more approachable and
appealing
I actually think this article's kind of
giving me a big head
did you hear that
approachable
appealing
the article suggests that women are
effective in rendering extremist
ideologies more acceptable and
mainstream
so I'm mainstream now
wow effectively enticing individuals
into their belief systems using a softer
approach
so I'm soft
you know oh
stop it stop it you guys are so nice
The Surge of participating in Far Right
scene reflects a response to the
evolving dynamics of society where
social media wields significant
influence in amplifying and radicalizing
perspectives by capitalizing on the
online environment these women can
propagate content that aligns with
far-right ideologies
potentially leading susceptible
individuals to embrace those
perspectives
so they're calling me persuasive
this is amazing I'm having so
I hope they write more articles on me a
phenomenon often referred to as red
pilling the article
the article also delves into the Trad
wife movement
which Champions for traditional gender
roles and frequently covers covers
far-right ideologies you know what's
funny I was thinking about this where
they're like Pearl you just tell
everyone to get married and I'm like
I think I tell people not to get married
more than I pushed marriage
and recently I was thinking they're like
well Pearl you shouldn't start a gender
War
and I'm thinking why not really they're
just asking for women to be able to say
whatever they want and have no
consequence because there's been a
gender war on men for at least 50 years
and all of you guys were quiet but the
second were like all right let's
criticize women a little bit
now it's a gender War
how convenient how convenient is that
it's like
okay sorry
um
but yeah so that's why I was like you
know if anything it's really just
self-defense at this point from the man
this article um also delves into the
Trad my wife movement which Champions
traditional gender roles and frequently
covers far-right ideologies some
adherence of this movement advocate for
anti-feminism
homophobia
and transphobia employing their
conservative values as a platform to
challenge contemporary societal Norms
experts Express apprehension about the
political impact of female influencers
in advancing far-right agendas while
social media platforms have made
attempts to curb the dissemination of
extremist content these Endeavors aren't
always successful as alternative
platforms and communication methods
persist okay now they're set now they're
saying
that the all the company should ban us
and if they don't ban us
now they're whining about our about
Rumble really
law enforcement faces complexities in
addressing these challenges in
conclusion these articles accentuates
the mounting involvement of Women Within
the far-right and alt-right circles
particularly in the digital realm these
women employ diverse tactics to
propagate extremist ideologies and
persist a more engaging facade to lure
followers this trend underscores the
necessity for sustained vigilance and
awareness regarding the heterogeneous
array of individuals contributing to the
extremist movement well guys
I took that as a compliment so number
one they called me mainstream you know
number two they said I'm persuasive
number three they said I'm warm and soft
thank you Marie Claire thank you very
much that was a very nice article you
wrote Always a risk of investment and
there's no guarantee of any kind protect
your retirement with gold Ira or go to
www.just pearlythingsgold.com or call
877-646-5347 Noble gold is who I trust
the US has lost 85 percent of its value
since the 70s when the dollar decoupled
from gold and the government seems bent
on continuing the tradition from now
until after the next elections the
government can print as much money as
they want and the last time they did
that inflation went up nine percent gold
is the one asset that has proven to
withstand inflation invest in gold with
a noble asset Investments you will also
get a 24 carat quarter ounce gold
standard coin for free go to
noblegoldinvestments.com now that is
noblegoldinvestments.com
or simply dial
1-877-646-5347 Noble gold Investments
the only gold company that I trust uh
you know
speaking of mainstream you know I
actually think it's crazy that fresh and
fit haven't gone mainstream because the
amount of points the amount of points
these guys make is just insane so
there's a clip of Myron that is going
viral on Tick Tock where he is
predicting that all of these women
nowadays on social media are going to be
mentally ill in the next 20 years let's
take a look the next 10 to 20 years you
are going to see a spike in females
having mental instability problems
because of all the attention they're
getting thanks to Instagram I've seen
girls right like female celebrities
right from like the 2000 Etc they're all
going crazy why because they hit the
wall they're not able to have the same
sexual Market presence they used to have
10 15 years ago
Etc and they're famous here's the scary
part there's girls right now that have
not maybe Britney Spears level Fame but
damn near close Instagram model type
chicks that have that same level of
attention that they're getting that
Britney Spears was getting in the early
2000s and there's a lot of them so
you're gonna see a bunch of chicks going
crazy like Britney Spears because a lot
of girls are getting Britney Spears
level type attention today thanks to
social media y'all are going to see a
bunch of girls acting crazy like that
bro crazier crazier we did an episode uh
with this on Rollo remember the old lady
yeah that was like a model back in the
80s and 90s she was dating Rockstar the
Blondie she was really popular she was
like a model also the on Playboy
magazine all that other now she's
posting about how she doesn't get
attention anymore she's invisible all
this now mind you this girl yeah
she was popular she was kind of famous
Etc but there's girls that have been on
this show that have more clown Fame
right now than she did back then because
of social media yeah so if you see that
girl that was famous like that going
crazy having these withdrawals now I
could only imagine what awaits us the
next 10 to 30 years y'all are gonna see
a massive Spike of women going crazy bro
because they're getting all this
attention now emotional damage you're
not gonna know how to deal with it when
they no longer get that attention yeah
guys so I think I think Myron's
absolutely right I mean we basically
have been overloaded on attention from
the time we were we're super young and I
don't necessarily
it's kind of crazy around about how this
happened because why are women so
overloaded on attention it's because we
don't defer Authority in households to
the father
the father is given no say or authority
over his own children
um so typically what you'll see is a lot
of women getting on social media
sometimes pushed by the mother and even
though the dad isn't really for it he
doesn't do anything to stop it because
men don't get Authority in their own
household and the other problem is we
lie to men and women about females true
nature and the thing is this is why you
guys see so many young
TV and movie stars go crazy like Britney
Spears Miley Cyrus all of the Disney
stars that are going crazy
guys it's mostly women I mean some men
do too but it's not the same
even looking at Brittany Renner coming
on the show you know
I really do think there's a part of
women that wants to settle down and stop
doing this but the problem is
we we go on like attention withdrawals
so it's it's almost like an addict like
it's almost like a drug addict or an
alcoholic where we're so used to getting
like a certain amount of tension
attention and when it starts to get
taken away because you know Beauty only
lasts so long we start to go crazy we
first you know it's like the stages of
grief we first start to cope and say why
older women are hotties too and then
we're like oh okay and then we
start to do something about it so that's
when you'll see us like inject into
our faces you know fake hair fake nails
all of that stuff at some point there is
acceptance or going crazy and I actually
have this theory that a lot of the
actresses that have killed themselves
over the years like Marilyn Monroe were
in their mid-30s and it was because
they're kind of going nuts because the
attention was dying out because you'll
see like a lot of um like beautiful
celebrities commit suicide and if they
don't
like if they don't have a solid family
structure around them just a lot of
times they go nuts
um
and I I don't say this like I'm happy
about it I think on one hand I do think
women have been victims of the culture
but on the other hand we've made our own
bed and I I think at some point we got a
lie in it so you know I I think Myron's
absolutely right I think we're
overloaded on attention and I think that
in 10 20 years we're gonna go crazy you
see Amber Rose going crazy you see
Brittany Renner going a bit nuts and you
see us you know taking our clothes off
more and more and more and more to get
the attention that we're never gonna get
back I'm sorry there's nothing you can
do to get the attention you had at 18.
there's nothing you can do to get the
attention that you had at 21. it's gone
NADA and you can't get it back and the
problem is we just keep selling women
this dream of you're youthful forever
you're young forever you're gonna have
the same options in 10 years as you do
now and they're lying
and that's why I really just that's why
I go so hard on the Trad cons because
they're supposed to be the ones that are
telling us the truth
and
um a lot of times it's like they live in
just they live in a world that's just as
delusional as the left it's like the
left and the right on both sides are
pandering and Catering to women and we
have to get to a point where we can be
honest and that's why I really
I really urge men to be honest with
women
um you know men are repulsed by the fact
that we're not virgins men are repulsed
by the fact that we're overweight men
are repo pulsed by um honestly the
quality of wives on the market we just
don't know it because we've been
pandered to and catered to for a
lifetime
um and the problem is this attention
addiction leads to women uh making
really poor decisions an example of that
is the epidemic of only fans and the
problem is is when you have these
attention-addicted women with all the
freedom to do whatever we want
um there are consequences for the entire
family the US dollar has lost 85 percent
of its value since the 70s when the
dollar decoupled from gold and the
government seems bent on continuing this
tradition from now until after the next
elections the government can print as
much money as they want and the last
time they did that inflation went up
nine percent that means one thing the
security of your future and your
family's future is all in your hands
make sure you freeze the value of the
wealth you are holding invest in gold
with Noble gold Investments gold is the
one asset that has proven to withstand
recession inflation and just above all
economic threats Noble gold Investments
is here to help you if you want to
invest in gold you will also get a 24
Karat quarter ounce gold standard coin
for free go to Noble gold and
assessments.com now that is
noblegoldinvestments.com or simply call
1-877-646-5347 Noble gold Investments
the only gold company that I trust so
there's a story in the news today about
an only Fan's models son killed himself
so only fan star's son left suicidal
after classmates taught him with naked
pictures of his mom the 13 year old said
he had no idea his mom was on
provocative social media sites and
suffered panic attacks when youngsters
from his school began mocking him a
teenager said he had been left depressed
and suicidal after his classmates
flaunted naked pictures of his mom from
her only fans account
the 13 year old says he has no idea his
mother was on the provocative social
media site and suffered a panic attack
when youngsters from his school began
mocking him and shared naked pictures of
his mom he said he confronted his mother
about the only Fan's account and was
told he was overreacting with his mom
insisting that sex work is basically the
same as working in a supermarket
posting to Reddit the unnamed teenager
said I'm 13 and my mom is 33. things at
school were never great I'm sort of
short so I get picked on a bit but it
was manageable this that was until one
of my classmates showed me a picture of
my mom naked I almost had a panic attack
it had to be excused from the classroom
I ended up not showing up to school for
a few days faking sick I was hoping that
things would cool off but they didn't as
soon as I got to school almost everyone
in class was staring and laughing at me
this has been going on for about a week
now the teenager says the bullying is
gradually getting worse and worse and
now lots of students have nude images of
his mom they're sharing online and his
mother shared a link to her only fans on
her personal Twitter page he continued I
was wondering how my classmates even got
the picture and apparently my mom
advertises her only fans on her personal
Twitter account some students from my
school follow her so they were able to
see the nudes and they have been spread
everywhere I don't even have a Twitter
so I didn't know about any of this the
worst part was when I confronted my mom
about this she told me I was
overreacting that sex work is basically
the same as working at a bank or a
grocery store she said it also makes her
feel good about herself that I should be
happy she's more confident now
I I told the principal but they can't
suspend thousands of students or take
anyone's phones I've been crying in my
room every day for the past week I don't
think I can take it anymore
we see wrongful deaths death suits all
the time for institutions that push
people into suicide you know schools
um even ex-lovers girlfriends boyfriends
but why is there no accountability on
mothers that push their sons into
suicide for their own poor decisions and
it's so funny because
the moms are so incredibly selfish
they are so selfish were they just think
of themselves and they don't think about
the kids at all
and you know
oftentimes what I'll hear
is that this is just a fringe case but
when you have more only fans workers
than teachers now
um this is becoming a real problem in
society and what a lot of these women
say is that oh you know once they're old
enough they'll understand
I think this is so selfish it is so
wrong and I actually
think it's terrible that we live in a
society that wants to make this socially
acceptable the most important thing in a
society is the children
children are innocent they had nothing
to do with the world's problems yet we
want to keep forcing our problems onto
the children
um
yeah so I I think this is unacceptable
and I I think that we really need to I
think we should ban only fans I think we
should
I think the U.S should ban only fans
because
and and this is another reason why men
should have the children because at
least when men are sleeping around or
you know do being a dog whatever they're
wise enough to keep it away from the
children
but women are just it's like they have
the audacity it's so crazy our next
story is about a UFC fighter that
recently
want one something I've never heard of
this guy I'm sorry guys I'm not into
sports but the UFC fighter um Sean
O'Malley claims he is entitled to cheat
on his wife because he pays for
everything so the rumor has it that Sean
O'Malley actually had an open
relationship with his wife until he got
into red pill content and they actually
closed it up and you know this is why I
talk so much about high value men
cheating I don't
guys I don't I don't say this like I'm
happy about it I don't say this like you
should do it but I think if women go
after the top 15 percent of men
they should expect
that he might cheat the same way then if
they go for the top 15 percent of women
they know that she might leave for a
better option
um I mean this is like water is wet the
sky is blue yet Trad cons want me to not
live in reality when the truth of the
matter is that the top 15 percent of men
have always had concubines for all of
history and why do you think this part
of history is any different now I'm not
saying it's a good thing I'm not saying
they should do it but the funny thing is
what is the difference between doing
this
and having multiple marriages
which we see all the time you know and
the truth of the matter is most women do
not pick monogamy women are in control
sex men are in control of relationships
women do not choose to be monogamous to
the first man they sleep with they
typically leave only four percent of
women wait till they're married to have
sex so knowing this information
wouldn't it stand to reason
that most women
do not choose monogamy either but yeah
the top 15 percent of men have always
cheated will always cheat and if you
don't want that then go for a regular
guy and I think this is a little bit
more honest than saying to live in
delusion and expect that from a UFC
fighter last on the show today you know
I I guess people are liking my advice
you know I'm just out here given
relationship advice you know take it or
leave it you know what I mean so my
pregnant wife of 10 years is cheating on
me so this is a story from Reddit that I
was sent and asked to respond to so my
pregnant wife of 10 years is cheating on
me
wow
about six weeks ago we found out my wife
is pregnant about six hours ago I found
out she was cheating on me I wish I
could make this up and I swear it feels
like a bad dream I'm so shocked and
upset I've been with my wife for 10
years this year I thought our
relationship is great and I've never
felt more comfortable or happy we are
both 28. I'm gonna make this incredibly
long story short she has been cheating
with me for the last month and a half
with her ex apparently they talked on
Facebook when she reached out to him to
tell him happy birthday she instigated
by doing this I'm assuming they slept
together three times and hung out six
she was going to TJ Maxx sending me
pictures of baby clothes but also
hanging out with him this woman is my
world I did everything for her I was so
excited for this baby what we were
trying she swears it's mine and there's
no way it's his she but she lied saying
they only slept together once he told me
three times when she finally admitted it
she said she told them she loved him but
didn't mean it my thing is how would she
love him after only a month they dated
like 13 years ago it's just hard for me
to believe and I'm questioning If the
child is even mine it's literally the
worst day of my life guys I'm terrified
my anxiety is awful I feel so sick she's
texting me saying she wants to work it
out but she's so shady apparently she
turned off Life 360 and her mom noticed
something was up it didn't tell me come
to find out she told her mom she saw saw
him but they were talking and nothing
more I have Life 360 on my phone because
my brother sister and wife wanted to be
in the loop with where I was which is
fine but I don't use it to track them
and never have I trusted her 100 it
doesn't feel real I'm hoping this is a
bad Nightmare and I have anxiety and
it's freaking me out so bad I can't
believe she did this to me we have a
home together all of our finances are
together this is the life I wanted and
now I don't know how to move on I'm so
betrayed she was the sweetest woman I've
ever met and I'm in shock and I don't
know how to feel
so this is actually a really common
Story one of the most common ways that
women cheat one is with men at work but
two is with ex-boyfriends and guys this
is why body count is so important
because women
for whatever reason we cannot go down
we we can't our our Natures once we hit
a certain lifestyle we can't go down you
know it's the same thing with men
unfortunately you know if we get a guy
that makes us feel a certain way
even even if it's not logical because a
lot of times guys will be like okay you
left me for a drug dealer you left me
for a criminal well the Criminal made us
you know feel a certain way we don't we
don't operate on logic we operate on our
feelings so the problem is
um a lot of women well
have an ex-boyfriend that they liked
better and if they get the chance
they'll go back and they'll cheat
unfortunately so and the other thing is
um just a red flag that I notice in
relationships women that wait a long
time to have kids after they get married
I just don't see them as that into the
guy because I mean think about it guys
guys women
want kids so bad with the top 10 20 of
dudes that they will literally
tell men that they're not on birth
control they'll steal condoms they'll do
all of this so I'm like if you've been
with a chick for 10 years
and she hasn't even tried you know I
mean I'm not saying she should but my
point is in my experience typically when
women want when a woman wants a kid with
a guy like it's immediate like if he's
that guy to her that's just my
experience
um
the other thing that I noticed is this
woman is my world so what does that tell
us when guys say that a woman is their
world
it's messing up the natural order of
things because he put her above himself
and women we hate it when you make us
the center of your world it is repulsive
to us we hate it
um another thing I I another thing I
noticed is I trusted her a hundred
percent
we're women you know what I mean it's
like and I don't say this I don't say
this to like to not I don't say this to
on women but guys we have a nature
and women are just a bit more especially
socially manipulative there are good
women that aren't going to use that part
of themselves but we have an inherent
nature and and that's the point so you
know guys let me know what you think in
the comments maybe I'm crazy uh my
advice to Reddit guy
Leave Her She's Gotta Go
um I know I know she's
you love her and all that stuff but okay
one kid look at even if the kid is yours
and I know I know you're like Pearl you
say keep the families together
this is too much this is I I don't think
there's any coming back from this so I
think if he stays with her it's just
gonna be a lifetime of misery
sometimes there's double standards but
let me know what you guys think in the
comments guys like the video on your way
out
um subscribe to the channel and I'll
talk to you next time